no ha perdido ninguna de sus capacidades
intelectuales pero ella no se puede
mover Hace cuatro años muna fue
diagnosticada con esclerosis lateral
amiotrófica conocida como Ela que
paraliza sus músculos y debilita su
dicción
El doctor me dijo que tenía una
enfermedad degenerativa no hay cura solo
debo vivir con eso soy una persona
positiva intento superar esta situación
resistirla antes de enfermarse muna era
profesora de literatura hoy en día su
vida se divide entre su casa y la unidad
de cuidados paliativos donde el personal
sanitario intenta aliviar su dolor tanto
físico como psicológico
los médicos están aquí para escuchar
hablamos reímos nos tomamos el pelo y
eso es el apoyo psicológico
sobre su mesa de noche hay algunas fotos
de ella con su esposo antes de
enfermarse y mientras el debate sobre el
fin de vida agita Francia muna se niega
a recurrir a la muerte asistida
no pienso en la muerte creo que cada uno
es libre de decidir su destino si uno
elige morir es su elección yo escogí la
vida
si algún día su esposa decide terminar
con su vida
yo diría que sí estoy de acuerdo es una
decisión
eso es libertad lo que digan
actualmente la legislación francesa no
permitía una poner fin a su vida
mediante el suicidio medicamente
asistido debería ir afuera como lo hacen
muchos franceses viajando a países
vecinos como Suiza y Bélgica que
autorizan la eutanasia por lo tanto el
costo del viaje para los que están
gravemente enfermos puede ser un
obstáculo a partir de este viernes un
consejo ciudadano francés de 150
integrantes se reúne para iniciar un
debate sobre los cuidados al final de la
vida incluida la legalización ONU del
suicidio asistido